The women's
college basketball tournament
has been around for four decades,
but the NCAA has long
treated it
as something of an afterthought.
For instance, the team contract
for the men's tournament
is worth $1.1 billion a year.
But the NCAA values
broadcast rights for the women.
Look, at that little line
at about $6 million a year.
Joining me now
is Hall of Fame
coach Muffet McGraw,
who won two
national titles at Notre
Dame during her 33 years
leading the Irish coach.
Thanks for coming in. My pleasure.
I think that most people
will be surprised.
I know I was to find out
that that women
were not allowed to use the March Madness
branding until last year.
2022 was the first time
you could call your tournament
March Madness
and it didn't cost the NCAA a sense.
So why did it take so long?
Well, that's
one of the things that you saw
with the debacle
you talked about a few years ago
when the men's and women's
tournament were held at the same place
and completely, completely different.
The women's on the court
branding was not existent, really.
It would say women's tournament.
We weren't allowed to use March Madness
for whatever reason, I'm not sure.
But we've never really been valued
the way we should.
I showed Governor Baker
that infamous video
that was taken at the 20, 21 tournament
showing that the facilities for the men
versus the facilities for the women.
Governor Baker said since then and March
Madness is one example
that there have been efforts to
to move somewhat
more to a level playing field.
How big a disparity,
though, is there still
in between the men's game
and the women's gap?
Well, it's huge.
And I think if you want to know
how we are valued for the NCAA,
the women's vice
president of basketball reports
to the men's vice
president of basketball.
So that shows
you exactly how important
they think the women's tournament is,
because we don't even report
to the president of the NCAA
at the end of the year.
When you win a national championship,
do you know how much the women make?
We get zero.
And the men, of course,
are making millions
and millions of dollars.
So if there's a way that they can get
some of those units
over to the women's side,
I think that will be something
that would really help the gender equity.
And you mentioned the TV.
We are lumped in
with a lot of other championships.
So it's not just women's basketball.
We're in with,
you know, every other championship
that they have,
they need to take us down
and sell and market
and promote us for what we're worth.
So you heard Governor Baker,
the new head of the NCAA.
What did you think of what he had
to say on this issue?
And as he begins his new term,
what is the single biggest thing
that you would like to see him
do to try to deal with the disparity
between the men's and women's game?
I think we're excited
that we have a politician in there,
because I think that's what
we're going to need somebody
that's willing to compromise, negotiate
and understands
the value of what the women
can bring to the NCAA
and to the tournament.
I think he's
got a lot of things on his plate
between the transfer portal, the nil
and in
and really just valuing women
and making our tournament
equal to the men.
You know,
we've been talking a lot tonight
about those specific issues,
the port hall, the name, image, likeness.
There's not as much money
that is spent on women players
as men's players.
Whether that's right or wrong,
it just is a fact.
Does it
have, though,
those rules
that have the same possibility
of changing the game
as much as it does on the men's side?
I absolutely think it does.
And I think that the transfer portal
Charlie mentioned, it's called
the one time transfer.
And yet you see that there are women
who have played in two, three
and even four schools.
And my concern is,
what about the education?
What about that degree?
What are we teaching these kids?
That they come in
with one foot out the door
and they can go where they want
if it doesn't work out for them,
if they don't like what they're doing.
If they
transfer a second time,
then they have to sit out a year,
but they haven't had to sit out.
And that is the issue.
They've been able to transfer
numerous times without that penalty.
And that's been a real problem
because what
are we
teaching them about commitment
and staying
and fighting through adversity
and all the things that sports
really teaches you about life skills?
What are we preparing them for?
And how do you feel
about the whole idea that
there are two sides to this argument?
One is
their athletes are getting an education.
The other is there.
Everybody else is benefiting off them.
They're being used.
Where are you on the whole question?
Of players being paid?
Well,
I don't think anybody
is opposed to players making some money,
but I don't believe in pay for play.
I don't believe that
you should make $1,000,000
just because you're the quarterback.
If somebody jerseys sells,
maybe they should make
some money from that.
But I think it's really ruining
college sports with where we are
because the team with the most
money is the one that's going to win.
If I offer you $100,000
to play at Notre Dame
and somebody offered you 300,000,
where are you going to go?
It's not about the fear
and it's not about the degree.
It's not about the education anymore.
It's about the money.
Coach McGraw, thank you.
Thanks so much for coming in and
talking with us about this.